While I was working as a Fire Chief,
working hard around
cardiac arrest survival, training
people in CPR in our community and
putting AEDs in the community,
but I was out to lunch one day.
I heard a siren in the distance.
It grew louder and ended up pulling
right in front of a deli where I was
eating, that's when I learned that
somebody right next door had suffered
a cardiac arrest, and I wasn't aware
of that until that ambulance got there.
That event made me realize that
even though somebody's trained,
they're not always in the exact right
place and the exact right time, and
maybe we can bring technology in, where
firefighters are alerted with radios,
maybe we could use people's cell phones,
who are trained in CPR,
even our off duty professionals,
make them aware of the events that
they were close too but couldn't see.
We're crowdsourcing good Samaritans,
that's really the purpose
of the Pulse Point app.
The solution that we have,
only can exist with a mobile app,
where you have push notifications,
you have location based services,
you have people carrying phones who
have the sophistication to do this.
We have an entirely
volunteer development team.
So Android being so widely adopted,
it's a platform when we put our
development time into that,
we know it's going to get into
the hands of a lot of users.
As a fire chief I didn't have app
developers, no programmers on my staff.
But we understood the problem very well.
So we ended up turning to a university,
NKU, Northern Kentucky University,
who had an app development school.
And we brought out
a number of interns and
sucked them up here in the Bay area,
and prototyped using interns.
Once we've proven the concept,
that's when we turned to deductial and
workday and they sort of helped
take the concept and make it real.
When you first load the application,
it shows you all the emergencies that
are happening around you,
not just cardiac arrests.
If you want to be notified
of cardiac arrests,
you just go into the setting screen and
you select the CPR notification.
Once you've done that, if a cardiac
arrest occurs within walking distance of
you, you'll be notified.
And you'll receive a map, and
it'll show you where you are,
where the patient's located, and
any nearby public access defibrillators.
The app also provides CPR instructions.
So reminders, and also a metronome
that can help you set the proper
cadence of your chest compressions.
You can't solve this
upfront on a white board.
It's a constant iteration,
learning from your users,
getting experience in the field.
And you have to be in the game.
You have to actually be solving
the problem to be able to learn enough
to make a difference.
We had somebody playing soccer,
at a local school,
collapse with cardiac arrest,
911 is called, and we have
an EMT who's home with his family that
lives across the street from the school.
Gets notified, just runs across the
street to do CPR, an event he would not
have been aware of but very close by,
and saved the gentleman's life.
So it's actually seeing the app save
lives, those are where you say,
we really made a difference
in these people's lives.
And we have so much potential to
do it again, and again, and again.